[Musique]
mais ce n'est pas de faire du foot
commençait très petit la boxe boxe pieds
poings à l'âge de six ans après petit
j'ai arrêté je suis revenu en boxe
anglaise
19 20 en une dizaine d'années maintenant
[Musique]
dès novembre 2017 avec un combat qui a
eu lieu au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ici c'est
avant tout dans la continuité
la boxe que j'aime c'est
entre lui-même
non jamais
h 2
28 ans on se dit bon allez pas de
regrets pourquoi pas passée en pro
tu as tu de tes chances je veux pas
avoir de regrets donc on y va et qu'il
advienne que pourra
pour l'instant j'ai eu
cinq combats avec une majorité de
défaite plus ou moins justifiées mais
une majorité des fêtes
avec quand même qu'à la victoire c'est
ça va jamais très loin donc
et puis on voit l'évolution qu'elle est
ça donne envie un peu de continuer
[Musique]
et
le poème c'est qu'on développement de
carrière
boxe féminine c'est jamais très facile
de se projeter sur du moyen terme du
long terme
c'est surtout les opportunités comme ce
qui s'est passé là lors de mon dernier
combat ce qui était quand même un
championnat de france parce qu'on l'a
pris au vol une opportunité qui s'est
présentée
c'est plutôt comme ça que je vais
rebondir
hier général on pense qu'ils nous ce qui
est potentiellement à notre portée
[Musique]